[Musique]
est ce qui se passe au bail à rendre ces
lier aux longs voyages qu'elle confesse
taipei fax et non je t'avais dit oh oh
la ola et franck ribéry qu'avec tous les
chiens ne pas passer non ces grandes
fermes ta vu un super beau pour toi
frère et je t'aime trop haute et un
amour frérot merci encore d'un amour est
franchement honteux type et camille les
commandes deux fois énorme et non mais
on dit comme des oufs à la et on t'aime
fort et un amour tu nous appelles de
paix le bayern munich c'est le parlement
ait battu embrassera birgit une jeune
fille a vécu jeunes amoureux
s'embrassent pour que vos d'amour et aux
thèmes à tout le monde et on t'aime très
fort merci vos premiers forte
merci frère au tempo c'est une bombe
franchement très belle surprise
et franck ribéry est donc de munich sa
s'est passé 4 ares assez classe as assez
cassé